we are pleased to announce the 1.0
release of the play billing library this
library includes convenience classes as
well as a wrapper for the billing
service allowing you to focus on
implementing your app specific logic to
use the library begin by adding the
following dependency in your
build.gradle file the next step is to
create a billing client instance you'll
use this class for interactions with the
in-app billing API including listing
available products starting the billing
flow for in-app products or
subscriptions opening the Google Play
payment screen getting users purchases
and creating or modifying subscriptions
when creating your billing client
instance you'll need to set a purchases
updated listener this allows your app to
receive updates from the in-app billing
API like transaction results and updates
from payments started in other devices
here's the code for creating the billing
client remember that it's required that
you set a purchase is updated listener
after you've successfully created the
billing client instance you are ready to
start sending requests to the in-app
billing API it's just a few lines of
code to get the details about a SKU or
to start the purchase flow for more
details about billing client purchases
updated listener and the full
documentation check out the Play billing
library page if you want to see a
step-by-step guide about how to
implement the play billing library in
your project visit the training class
for details of how to use the play
billing library including support for
Android wear and Android TV check the
updated version of the trivial jive v2
sample we also prepared a blog post as a
QuickStart guide and don't forget to
check out all the docs thanks for
watching
[Music]